Ok.
Operations
to stir up your chamber pressure.
Three seconds under the test flight of the inaugural vehicle
tower clear,
Linda picks over the Paulson reports.
First stage agents.
No,
what a sight when the came at twice,
the thrust of the
signal throttle down and
throttle back up through the
period of maximum aerodynamic pressure.
The velocity increases the density of the atmosphere is decreasing,
less stress on the vehicle to call out next.
Now
continuing to watch the first stage as we head down range
100 seconds into flight.
Our next major activity is the first stage,
the Houston tracking station.
Now acquiring the vehicle shut down,
we will get separation of super heavy and ignition of the starship
engines.
When starship separates,
we light up six engines in a staggered sequence.
If all goes well,
those six engines will burn for almost 6.5 minutes on board.
View from view
of the raft engines on the second stage as we prepare for state
separation.
After state separation,
the first stage will flip and begin a boost back maneuver for landing in the Gulf
continuing to fly two minutes.
40 seconds.
Let's get ready for main engine cut off
beginning the flip for stage separation
something OK.
As of right now,
we are awaiting stage separation where a
starship should separate from the super heavy booster
right now.
It looks like we saw the start of the flip.
But obviously,
we're seeing from the ground cameras,
the entire starship stack continuing to rotate.
We should have had separation by now.
Obviously,
this does not appear to be a nominal situation.
Yeah,
it does appear to be spinning.
But I do want to remind everyone that everything after clearing the
tower was icing on the cake
and there as you saw as we promise and to the
scholarship inaugural integrated test,
right?